okay here's a great question from violet
ivy2 on the youtube asks a lot of baby
boomers retired as a result of the
pandemic and the u.s needs people in
various industries including healthcare
what do you think the best way to
address this is hmm
if only there was a way get more people
to go to work hmm
what would we do huh well let's take a
career nursing
plumbing uh why don't we make it free to
get those degrees or make those degrees
with an isa
and income sharing agreement where we
offer it for free
or
based on uh you know
taking back one and a half times the
educational cost over ten years over
seven years whatever it is like let's
really incentivize people another way to
get people to go back to work is to
raise the uh raise salaries that's
happening
another way to get people to come back
to work is to make them feel respected
to make them feel a sense of mission or
purpose in their job not easy to do but
also not impossible so i think labor
has the advantage right now because you
have a combination of things happening
obviously stimulus gave people more
runway and the double unemployment
situation which is ending all of that
gave people a lot of runway people's
homes increased in value that gives
people extra runway people reevaluated
their lives and said you know what i
have enough money in the bank i want to
take the next 10 years and go skiing no
i'm not doing that to my team who's
wondering what i'm going to just pull
the rift cord i love coming to work
every day um i should could enjoy some
more skiing though um putting that aside
uh
yeah raise salaries train more people
and then here's a crazy idea
hear me out
if we have more jobs open
then people willing to take them
then maybe
call me crazy
we could allow some highly skilled
people into the country
since americans don't want those jobs we
are so
privileged in this company i'm sorry
we're so privileged a little friends
we're so privileged in this country
to have so many opportunities
that people are so affluent that they
can turn them down
that is something we should celebrate
it's america's so great
a lot of people don't need to go to work
and they're happy not going to work
they've either made enough
lowered their burn or some combination
of the two or become micro entrepreneurs
where they do projects and they make
money for three months and then take six
months off congratulations but let's be
honest here if we got 11 million job
openings and under five percent
unemployment maybe it's time for us to
talk about a point-based system at the
border
what does it mean
it means to just take the emotion
out of and the polarization out of
immigration immigration shouldn't be all
or nothing it shouldn't be about
your evil or your you know mother teresa
there's a lot of nuance here everybody
coming into the country
provides some amount of value
some people might be a drag when they
first get here and then eventually
become
uh you know contributors right
somebody who comes here and uses social
services needs an education
it might actually be a drag for some
period of time and you're making an
investment with the hope and i think
it's a reasonable one that they will pay
off in their taxes and their
contribution decided later kind of works
for all of us and our parents right and
our grandparents who came here i don't
see why it wouldn't work in the future
but since this country is very
attractive people around the world we
might get a disproportionate amount of
people want to come here
and since a
disproportionate number of people want
to come here we do need to have some
limits why don't we tie the number of
jobs that are available to the number of
people that we let in so in other words
you take the last five years you have a
rolling average of the last 200 weeks
250 weeks of unemployment data
you look at it and say what jobs are
open okay teachers doctors lawyers
construction okay great let's take out
construction great where can we get
incredibly trained construction people
great if you're applying and you say
i've got 12 years experience in
construction i'm a plumber i'm an
electrician great we need more of those
looking back at these four
years
we need uh we will give a preference to
what we actually need in the country
is that too cutthroat or is that logical
because you do want to have product
market fit here you do want to have
immigrant job fit it doesn't help
anybody if we had i don't know
we if we let's just suppose that we had
i don't know too many nurses it's not
the case but
letting in a million nurses or a hundred
thousand nurses and they can't find jobs
that doesn't help anybody that hurts
them because now they got to take a job
that they're not satisfied with and it
hurts the entire
base of nurses because maybe salaries
get lowered and that's not good either
so how about some logic and then oh they
want to invest in the country great so
we'll hold 20 percent of slots for
people who are willing to invest a
million dollars or a half million
dollars yeah they're buying their way in
yeah they're buying their way into great
businesses so other people get jobs
that's a good thing
you want to let some people buy the
front first class seats those first
class seats are what make the seats in
the back so cheap that's smart
overcharge them
if i told you we were going to put in
the front of a plane
you know two private bedrooms and they
were gonna cost twenty five thousand
dollars each to go to italy and
that everybody who was in coach instead
of paying eight hundred dollars got to
pay 650 who's not taking that deal
we're all taking that deal yeah go below
25 large on a bedroom in the front of
the cabin
mazel tov great
that's what we need to do
we need to look at this and say
let's have a sorting mechanism here okay
this person is going to go back to their
country and be murdered because of their
race religion creed color whatever
yeah we we need to keep 20 of the 20 of
the spots for people who are refugees
who are going to face imminent harm
death persecution if they go back to
their country right so people come from
cuba
or they come from venezuela or they come
from china or russia and we know hey if
they go back they're just going to be
put into gulag and tortured and murdered
or worse
let's keep them here you know like we
could have some sympathy um and the
point-based system could also be
uh how easy how easily will you
integrate into society well what makes
it easier to integrate into society
speaking the language a lot of other
countries do this by the way
a point-based system in the uk
point-based system in canada point-based
system i think new zealand and australia
i'm sure of australia i'm pretty sure in
new zealand so the point-based system is
super um i think fair and it changes the
discussion from
you're a horrible republican who
is a xenophobe or you are a bleeding
heart liberal who just wants to create
chaos at the border
that's not actually what's happening uh
in other countries they're just saying
let's be thoughtful about it let's be
thoughtful if a person has a college
degree and speaks english fluently are
they going to have an easier time coming
to america or canada
of course they are well that's what the
other countries do that's what canada
does if you have a degree or a master's
degree or a phd you get points for each
of those and that gives you a greater
chance of getting in does anybody argue
with that so anyway that's a long-winded
answer to
you know what do we do about uh the job
problem i think sensible immigration
which i just want to attend on
is something i've been researching
because
i'm an idiot i had no idea how any of
this works and i kept asking during this
whole back and forth of politicians
fighting hey um what's the actual number
and i couldn't find it in any of the
stories new york times wall street
journal washington post nobody ever
mentioned how many people came in last
year how many people came in this month
how many people
you know got in because of h1b versus
this they never talk about the actual
numbers
i i always start with the data but these
government officials are so polarized
they don't start with the data they
start with the emotion
is that a good idea if you're flying a
plane
should you get into the cockpit and say
you know what how am i feeling right now
am i scared am i nervous i'm angry am i
happy what should you say
what's our altitude what's our speed
uh okay uh how's the plane flying you
know
like maybe look at the can we just look
at the gauges and just make a decision
to keep the plane flying
you know smoothly that's what we should
be doing with our government they should
be keeping the plane
flying smoothly less turbulence all
right end of rent
okay sock to comply